[Applaudissements]
alors ma première impression lorsque je
reçois un court film conte pour dire
nous citerons vous invitez initiative
qui s'appelle le tmx
alors là je vous assure était assis au
bureau et d'y écouter mais c'est quoi il
s'agit
on l a effecté c'est une conférence pour
vous les partager les idées et donc du
coup vous avez été choisis à cet effet
poursuit-il ya problème je réponds à vos
appels
et donc on se retrouve là aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir partager effectivement ses
respirations
les six yamoussa
et étudier à haute guinée plus
précisément à siguiri et donc du coup je
suis venu à l'université j'ai fait quand
j'ai fait mes études supérieures
et s'est félicité de kankan vous ici
développé en biologie médicale
et donc j'ai fait au moins sur deux ans
ni promotion de la santé
je suis activistes de la société civile
parce qu'il faut le mois il faudra
essayer de changer quelque chose au
quotidien et donc du coup il ya des
questions qui traversent la tête chaque
fois qu'est ce que je fais qui peut
changer quelque chose autour de noms ces
questions mais traverse chaque fois et
ça m'amène un côté activis donc
différent karman de profession à
l'hôpital pour pouvoir essayer de
s'occuper des patients
alors
l'activisme que c'est en train de faire
au quotidien
le constat est assez simple lorsqu'on
est à l'hopital recevons tous les jours
les usagers qui viennent nous voir qui
nous pose le problème est que nous avons
le devoir de trouver des solutions à
leurs problèmes
je trouve qu'ils sont confrontés à des
différents problèmes à des niveaux
différents
d'autres problèmes par exemple c'est
juste l'accès aux soins qui demandent
pas grand chose mais qui mérite une
attention de réflexion vous dire qu'est
ce qu'il faut
alors dire en tant que professionnels de
santé
il faut avoir une structure organisée
pour pouvoir essayer d'amener cette
incitation et avoir les lésions autour
d'une idée commune auxquels nous pouvons
défendre ensemble
là bas ou soan est loin des actions
médicales guinée qui mène des activités
sur le terrain aux côtés de la
population en tant que professionnel de
santé non seulement pour les favoriser
et faciliter l'accès aux soins mais
aussi à l'est les pro billets lorsque le
besoin se fera sentir
alors
nous sommes restés dans ce cadre
il y a des idées qui émergent
tout au long d'une initiative
il n'est pas tout à fait au rouge à
cette fois on fait les idées quand ça se
freine et les obstacles qui sont là tu
as i qu'est ce qu'il faut pour que ça
puisse bouger parce que chaque fois
qu'ils étaient mis d faut que tu essaies
de réfléchir qu'est ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir essayer de bouger d'un cap un
autre c'est extrêmement important en
tant que jeune j'ai compris ce défi très
tôt en quittant l'université par exemple
je me suis dit pratiquement il faut que
dr cissé
devient quelqu'un quelque part un temps
quand il le faut donc c'est un objectif
très clair
une retraite juste et j'essaie de me
poser tes dans dix ans qu'est ce que je
veux que ce soit alors ces initiatives
personnelles ces deux réflexions
personnelles c'est juste assis en train
de réfléchir dans dix ans qu'est ce que
tu veux devenir et ensuite fléchi pour
avoir les moyens pour avoir ça et donc
défini de l'université tout de suite
j'essaie de le constater rapidement
et les étudiants qui vont faire une
manifestation très rapidement on
pourrait bien coûter au mois plus un peu
plus soutenir et vous savez la
soutenance dans les universités
ça permet à l'étudiant d'être vraiment
dans le mécanisme de recherche et puis
l'initiation et donc du coup moi je me
suis dit
mais vu que l'ensemble des étudiants est
l'argument était fort à l'époque ça a
été même le motif du départ de notre
livre de notre recteur et donc du coup
les souterrains sont bannis
moi je suis venu voir au décollage et
d'écouté il faut que je soutiens et je
suis rentrée à l'université pour
soutenir et puis pour avancer parce que
sans ça je me sens limité
mais qui à 6 mai demandé 10 m'écouter
toi tu peux pas faire obstruction aux
problèmes si vous me demandez nous
allons vous donner
ainsi en me donnant m
j'essaie de m'y mettre et puis je
soutiens en 2009 je crois qu'il a été le
premier c'était le seul à soutenir en
2009 au département souligne hervé
option biomédicales à l'université je
crois que ce témoin existe jusqu'à
présent
d'autres personnes
ont pris l'exemple même si en la fin de
l'été on les donnait leur diplôme pour
sortir et dit non nous aussi nous
voulons soutenir
c'est pour vous dire que ces initiatives
personnelles des fois qu'on savait pas
il faut qu'on aille au delà mais ce que
nous voulons
après avoir soutenu je me suis dit non
ce n'est qu'un début de quelque chose
parce qu'il faut toujours essayer de
voir cette dimension de se démarquer
pour rester un peu à l'image de zoé les
autres chaque groupe chaque entité
auquel
personnellement je puisse
adhérer j'essaie de faire le maximum
pour que dès qu'on tape à la porte en
lui non c'est cissé qui est là quand
vous avez cette idée
c'est à dire que ce sens
de réussite
ou bien cette énergie en vous je vous
assure à chaque fois que vous tentez de
faire quelque chose vous y arriver parce
que dieu est pour tout le monde
alors
c'est ça qui nous amène à mettre en
place des structures donc des idées
comme ce que nous sommes en train de
partager aujourd'hui pour inciter
d'autres personnes à faire mieux
la collection d'art des professionnels
de santé et une initiation parfaite
parce que c'est des jeunes qui se sont
retrouvés pour but d écouter et il ya un
problème et voilà nous ne pouvons
apporter quelque chose
et je crois que c'est en train de donner
tout son sens parce que nous sommes en
écouter et ça puisse changer la vie des
millions de personnes là où nous en
sommes en train de vous partager cette
violence
il prend l'exemple sur le thème comme
cole
par rapport à l'expérience
de notre pays face à la poignée au kobus
10 nov
alors
je crois que le but du mans le 12 mars
lorsque la guinée recevait son premier
car
nous étions autour d'une activité qu'on
appelle
la ville d'installer l'apprentissage
d'un logiciel qui permet de faire la
budgétisation du plan stratégique de la
santé de la mère et de la omra de la
santé de mortalité maternelle et de la
direction nationale de santé familiale
de la nutrition
akwaya nous sommes restés on a reçu en
cours et ils ont dit que le premier cas
de grippe 19 et déclaré un recul de
guinée
me rétracte issus
d'anciennes endroit là où j'étais seul
je réfléchis et en tant qu'activiste en
tant que personnel de santé qu'est ce
que nous devons faire par rapport à ça
vu que
le monde entier 10 a été sous le feu de
l'action et donc du coup je me suis dit
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour qu'on puisse
apporter notre contribution
vu que c'était une première
alors tout simplement je suis venu
essayer de contacter les amis nous faut
un plan de sortie de crise en guinée
même le gouvernement je sens qu'ici
c'est dans l'anticipation faut faire les
choses
mais de la façon que nous avons fait de
façon professionnelle détaillé un plan
de sortie de crise avec une publication
officielle
la danse notion de risque sanitaire
je crois que ça a été tout son salut qu
on peut dire que oui nous avons une
proposition très concrète pour pouvoir
essayer de nous faire sortir si vous
essayez de regarder un peu ce que d'un
souffle en de claquer un document de
travail qui a été réalisé et donc du
coup la danse nationale de sécurité
sanitaire a su faire ce qu'il voulait
faire par rapport à ça c'est pour vous
dire que où que vous soyez il faudra
vous dire que oui vous avez un potentiel
à vous que vous pouvez essayer de vous
servir et faire quelque chose avec
c'est pas de la richesse c'est pas de la
pauvreté
chacun de nous à quelques choses
personnelles auxquelles il faudra
essayer d'exploiter et c'est là bas
qu'ils en appellent la conscience deux
ans et des autres on peut dire il faut
démultiplier ses expériences et
initiatives et c'est là bas que j'ai
c'est de l'afflux de passage que
pourquoi on n'a pas de ty en guinée
c'est pour lui qu'ils finissent yati
vous qui savez forcément aller quelque
part source d'inspiration qui pourra
inciter vers les idées positives pour
que le monde puisse changer la guinée
doit changer parce que les idées
positives il y en a chez nous et nous
pouvons faire quelque chose avec ça
compte dans son domaine sans pouvoir
pour ce qui est in de part et d'autre
alors pour ne pas être très tôt
moi c'est un devoir et un plaisir de
venir partager ce que nous sommes en
train de faire au quotidien comme pour
dire si vous n'êtes pas une bulle
quelque part je vous assure que vous
pouvez casser ces bulles lorsque vous
comprendrez que oui vous avez un
potentiel que vous pouvez exploiter et
puis en faire quelque chose pour changer
quelque chose autour de vous dans le
pays dans le monde et donc du coup ça
donne tout son sens à votre existence
est en cela que le monde pour aller
mieux je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]